thank you all for attending my name is
mark johnson i am a virologist at the
university of missouri
um until the pandemic camp hit i used to
be a molecular virologist that worked on
hiv replication
but in pandemic times i have become a
specialist in
monitoring viruses through wastewater
which is something i was not expecting
the work i'm going to show you today is
a collaboration with the missouri state
health department and the missouri
department of natural resources
if you're not familiar this is the state
of missouri this is currently the places
where we are sampling wastewater to look
at stars cov2 levels and
lineages
at this point we're at about 102
communities as well as 36 state
facilities which includes all of our
prisons plus some veterans home
psychiatric hospitals and other sites
we have a website anyone can go to it's
live you can look and see we update it
every week to show what's happening in
terms of raw wastewater stars cody2 rna
levels so this is just sort of will
reflect what's happening in your
community the red triangles means that
the number the the rna levels are going
up so
almost 100 of the time reflects
increases in patient levels in those
locations
but what i'm mostly going to talk about
today is
our efforts in sequencing sarsko v2 and
the lineages through wastewater
and i have to confess that when i first
started this project i didn't think
there was going to be any point in this
kind of project
but
i changed my mind largely after i
paper that i'm going to quickly
summarize for you it was first submitted
by jesse bloom's lab in december of 2020
this is right around the time we were
seeing the first variants appear this is
when the uk and or alpha beta and gamma
were starting to hit the scene
but if you recall
from when the
when stars kobe 2 first started its
pandemic until practically the end of
2020 there was very little variation in
the sequences of source code v2 there
was maybe one mutation the d614g which
had really taken over but there weren't
a whole lot of changes that we were
seeing in sequences at least not that
were seeming to
really take off which kind of surprised
me because i would have expected it to
adapt a bit more when it jumped into a
new host but that's what happened so i
if nothing happened after the first you
know nine months i wasn't necessarily
expecting anything to happen but then
in this manuscript
what they did is they looked at another
coronaviruses it's coronavirus that's
been infecting humans for quite some
time at least 50 years which is this
called 229e it's a coronavirus that will
cause a common cold
and what they did is they looked back in
time
at the at lineages and how they changed
over the decades
and there were three main
points i want to highlight from this
manuscript the first thing they found
which is i find amazing is that this
virus evolves over time but as a single
worldwide lineage
which means that in 2020 the 229e in
china and u.s and brazil and south
africa are all going to be more similar
to each other than from a 229e from five
years earlier it seems that there's one
sort of global strain that sort of
evolves together
the second thing was and this really
impressed me is that the virus is
clearly evolving resistance to our human
vaccine response or antibody response
there's no vaccine against it
the way they found this is because
they could collect they had serum from
patients at different periods in time
and they could check what viruses their
their antibodies were able to neutralize
what they found is
serum from a certain year could in fact
could block virus from that year but if
you took virus from a few years in the
future that virus will have gained
resistance to those antibodies very
clearly the virus was evolving to adapt
to the immune responses we were mounting
and then the final point was they
tracked down sort of what changes were
causing these resistance to the
antibodies and almost all of it tracked
to this spike protein
so
this graph at the bottom shows the
where there are mutations occurring
in this gene and this hot spot right
here where you see a lot of changes was
called the rbd or the receptor binding
domain this is the part of the product
that actually binds to the host this is
what determines tropism and this is
where most neutralizing antibodies
target there are a few other places on
the spike protein where the
where antibodies can neutralize but over
at least in humans over 90 of them will
target this receptor binding domain
one other thing just to point out is the
the spike protein has two pieces s1 and
s2 which are cleaved by a host
protease
and this is also an important area of
evolution
so once i read this paper i'm like
i was convinced that even if we hadn't
seen sarsko v2 mutating yet i was sure
it wasn't going to go away and
i was pretty sure it would start to
evolve once you know there was herd
immunity or something approaching herd
immunity
so we began the project of
sequencing um and again what we focused
on was despite protein so on that this
is a you know picture everyone seen in
stars could be two despite protein is a
red blob on the surface this this
protein has two jobs one is it binds to
the whole cell receptor which is called
ace2 and the second is it facilitates
penetration into the cell so it actually
causes the membrane of the cell to fuse
with the membrane of the virus
now there are a lot of groups that have
begun
characterizing soros cov2 when it just
through wastewater but there are
basically three approaches that can be
utilized to do this
the first is using qpr
and what you do here is you can design a
qpcr probe and
where you only get a signal if there's a
sequence that has a particular mutation
in it so you can screen for mutations
that are known to be in particular
lineages
um
these are these qptrs are great they're
fast they're quantitative and they're
they're fairly cheap
um but they have the disadvantage that
they're not really telling you about the
whole virus they're only telling you
about one nucleotide position in the
genome and there is a lot of redundancy
among the different lineages so it can
be misleading and you kind of have to
adapt to the virus
ever-changing landscape
the second approach is the one we use
which is a targeted sequencing so we
don't amplify the whole genome we only
amplify that region that i showed you is
likely to be evolving the receptor
binding domain and a few other spots on
the spike gene and because we're not
um sequencing the whole genome we're
actually only amplifying a certain piece
which then we can sequence all together
so if there's multiple mutations we can
tell which mutations were derived from
the same lineage and that's really key
the disadvantage of this is it takes
longer it is more expensive and it can
be misleading in terms of quantitation
so
particularly when rna levels are really
low with you know patient levels are low
if you have if you extract
your waste water and you have a tube
where there's only 10 strands of rna and
you go to amplify and only one of those
10 amplify you're going to be missing
because you'll only know about that one
sequence so especially when it's low the
quantitation can be misleading so you
have to be cautious about that but
the big advantage is that it tells you
about the relevant region and it tells
you what things go together so it's
really a great way of seeing
what new sequences are
evolving
the third approach and this is the one
that most people use is whole genome
sequencing this is basically
using the same technologies used in
clinics to amplify and sequence the
entire genome of the virus so they the
way they do that is they break it up
into little tiny pieces and then
sequence them all together and they
throw it into a software pipeline and
then spits out what the whole sequence
was
this is an excellent approach when you
have a uniform sample but it gets a
little bit hairier when you're working
with something like wastewater where you
have a mix of
often many many different lineages so
what you end up with is is not a whole
sequence but you have basically a list
of all the mutations and polymorphisms
that are present and because it's done
in little bitty pieces you can't really
tell which mutations go together
this approach is still very effective at
figuring out what known lineages are
present but it's not as good at
determining if there's something new
just quickly this is our workflow
we get samples five days a week we
extract them the process we use takes
about six hours we always quantify them
the same day in which
the state which is almost immediately
put onto that website i showed you
when we go into the variant detection we
do two parallel things we do run some
qpcrs
against three of the known probes which
reflect some of the known variants of
concern and we do our targeted
amplification i mostly wanted to show
you these are the three sites that we'll
target the most important one is this
rbd receptor binding domain but we also
will sequence the n terminal domain and
the s1 s2 junction so almost all
neutralizing the antibodies will hit the
rbd or the ntd and the s1 s2 tells us
other things about the evolution of the
virus because often with many many many
of the variants of concern they have
mutations right at the fear and cleavage
site they're believed to enhance urine
cleavage
the fearing cleavage site was a recent
acquisition by this virus and it's
actually sub-optimal so it seems that
gaining a more efficient fear and
cleavage site enhances virus
replication somehow
this is the second map that is on our
dashboard this one actually shows which
variants we detected at the different
locations we started doing this with
samples in january and this is this was
the first round that we published on the
public dashboard when we began it was
kind of boring uh all of these brown
squares means that we didn't detect any
variants it was just the original the
same strain that we've been seeing all
through 2020.
we started this process just before the
alpha or the uk variant which i can't
stop calling it appeared in missouri on
this first round we saw a high
prevalence of the uk variant in only one
location which was part of st louis
however as the weeks went on
as everywhere the alpha variants sort of
spread out through the state what was
interesting to watch is that it spread
from sewer shed to sewer shed in a
fairly predictable manner first it sort
of filled out st louis and started to
work down the interstates
romantic sweaty can't say oh i should
mention these yellow triangles means
that there were multiple variants
present the green
cross means the only variant detected
was the uk variant
and so it sort of followed the
interstates and went through the
populace and then eventually made its
way out to all other rural communities
and eventually had by the end of april
it had fully displaced
the parent lineage we were no longer
detecting this the lineage as we were
seeing through all through 2020.
all through the year like most of the us
in 2020 the the cases were going down
down down
and
it seemed like it might be coming to an
end and then that all changed on may
10th
this was the first date when we detected
the delta variant in missouri and it was
one of the first outbreaks in the united
states actually
the first detection was in the city
called branson and if you aren't
familiar with it this is a real tourist
destination it's a very country western
themed location um
so a lot of people were traveling to and
from this
at the time this wasn't the delta
variant yet
the delta the word delta had not been
coined yet they hadn't come up with this
whole greek alphabet yet it was just one
of the india variants and it wasn't even
the first it was actually the third
india variant we had seen in missouri we
had seen the two others earlier in the
year
but delta or what it was at the time
called b617.2
is the one that the world health
organization had to had sort of said
appears to be the most infectious
version
um it was not actually a variant of
concern yet in the us for for some time
but
i i knew the world health organization's
recommendation so it really had my
attention
and sure enough within this is just 14
days later uh the next uh at a
collection and you could see that the
variant had just gone scatter shot
across the whole state
and unlike the alpha variant it didn't
follow this sort of follow the
interstates it just sort of went and
appeared everywhere so
immediately we were seeing it in rural
communities throughout the state and not
just in big populous areas
uh the
the term delta was actually coined on
may 31st
um but it wasn't con named a variant of
concern until mid-june by which point it
was
practically the only lineage present in
our state
uh this was june 14th this was the last
week where we or the last sampling i
believe when we detected a sample where
there was no
no delta
this is our this was the
latest reading from last week
these turquoise mean delta so it was the
only thing they were detecting
just want to show you what the output
looks like for me one of the tricks with
doing any kind of pcr-based sequencing
is pcr can do funny things to your
sequence they can there are sometimes
errors there are sometimes
recombinations and you have to be able
to sort out what's real and what's not
we published uh our our software
platform recently and we have a few
different software methods we use for
assembling the the data and sort of
pulling out and removing anything that
appears to be likely a pcr chimera or
polymorphism and this is what my output
looks like it comes out as a spreadsheet
of here's what we see l452r t478k if
you're not familiar that is the delta
variant in this case it was a little
over 70 percent
second one here was n501y a570d which is
the alpha variant the uk variant
and frequently we'll see a lot of an
extra polymorphism here and there
sometimes this is just a pcr error
sometimes not but fortunately you can
always look it up so like this is one i
had see i've seen many times it's it's
not even a amino acid change it's a
silent mutation at the amino acid 574 of
of the spike gene but i looked it up um
you can look on this thing called just
aid where you can blast and see any
sequence and sure enough this is a real
mutation seen in patients and it seems
to be enriched in missouri
but it's cool this is just to
demonstrate we see not only sort of the
raw lineage but new sub variants that
can go with it
now this slide is just to remind you
that we aren't just sequencing a few
sites we are collectively sequencing
about 150 different sites
so
what i'm going to show you next i can
say is unusual because it's something we
did not see very many of those 150
locations
so i'm going to tell you about this one
sewer shed in missouri
where when we first started sampling all
we detected was what i call here is
other so this pie chart just shows the
distribution of the sequences we pulled
out from the waste water
in january there was
nothing but the original strain but in
february is when the alpha variant first
moved in so on february 22nd we started
to see this b117 which is alpha uk
has many names
no surprises there but then something
surpr a little surprising happened
the first week of march
we detected the new lineage which had a
common mutation which is l452r
this had already been seen many times in
missouri it's found in the epsilon or
the california variant it's also one of
the mutations that's present in
the individual such as delta but this
was not delta and it was not the
california variant it was something else
and it also had another polymorphism
which was in 460k which is a
uncommon but not unheard of polymorphism
and spike
but what really means the week after
when we started to see some more
polymorphisms appear and they weren't
just anywhere they always were in the
backbone of this lineage that had
l452r we still had some of the 2020
strain we still had uk but we had these
new lineages and the part that really
freaked me out was this is that on the
second week we saw
in 460 k but we saw it twice we had
two different nucleotide changes at the
same position in the virus which both
led to the same amino acid change
which is
really flies in your face that there is
some kind of strong positive selection
going on here but it really wanted to
have this amino acid change
the next week again started to see more
of the variants and more polymorphisms
were appearing with time
after about four weeks we started to see
these new ones in 439 and in 440
and
some more as well
so this is just this lineage is just to
summarize that what this was not one
single lineage it was a bunch of
different
it was like a quasi species
they all had it was all made up of these
same nine polymorphisms but they had
different combinations of them um and
yeah it was really weird i had never
seen this kind of evolution from any
sewer shed with this virus usually
you'll see one or two and that's it here
we were seeing scores
so i i did a lot of digging to try and
figure out what was going on with these
mutations and this got me really this
this is another manuscript from
jesse bloom's lab where they took
the stars kobe 2 spike protein and they
made every possible single amino acid
change in the spike protein and they
tested them all to see
whether they had gained resistance to
any neutralizing antibodies and in this
case they were using the two
neutralizing antibody use in the eli
lily monoclonal therapy
so i mentioned before all
over 90 percent of neutralizing
antibodies target the stars cov2 spike
and they're broken into three or four
classes depending upon how they bind to
spike
and antibodies within the same class are
often
affected by mutations at the same
location so a mutation that blocks one
class while neutralizing the antibody is
likely to block multiple and what jumped
out so the way this looks is these are
shows the amino acids shown are ones
that cause resistance to
these two neutralizing antibodies bama
would never have or a test of a map
and what point now is these main
mutations that we were seeing off the
bat
were very highly select very much
enriched in their ability to neutralize
these
monoclonal antibodies
if you know regeneron is the other
company that has the these monoclonal
therapies and theirs they have a class
one and class three antibody and so
those uh positions that were coming up
late those 439 and 440 those were the
only ones that did not uh cause
resistance to the eli
they do cause resistance to regeneron so
pretty much every one of these amino
acid changes we've seen were either
affecting the receptor binding domain
properties or it was affecting
neutralization so at this point in time
what i thought was happening is we were
seeing resistance within people that
were receiving these therapies but i no
longer know if that is true
i suspect it is not
so i'm a virology lab so one of the cool
things we can do is
recreate some of these sequences in the
lab and make what's called
pseudo-particles and test their
properties so one of the things we did
is tested whether they are indeed
resistant to these neutralizing
antibodies and
shown here so the way this looks every
dot here represents an infection and
from left to right we add more and more
antibody
so this red line in the top left graph
is the wild type virus which i call
d614g
as you can see as you add more and more
neutralizing antibody you'll see less
and less viral infection whereas all all
four of or all three of the uh
mutants we're testing here which are all
combinations we saw from the missouri
sewer shed have resistance to class one
they all have resistance to class two as
well but only one of them has resistance
to class three which is the one that has
the n439k
so everything
behaved exactly as you would expect
based on its genotype
we also did some whole genome sequencing
what i was looking for here is i was
suspecting that this virus had
mutation in proofreading enzyme it just
seemed that it was mutating too fast so
i wanted to see if there are any
mutations in other parts of the genome
which might cause it to be a hype
something that was mutating faster than
normal but we found no such thing we
also learned that it's really hard to
tease out whole genome sequences from
this approach when it's a mixed sample
we know that this that this sewer shed
only had alpha gamma or v117 and t1 and
our oddball lineage but it was
impossible to try and tease out what the
three different full-length lineages
actually were
so it's yeah it's just really hard to
tease out a whole sequence when it's a
when it's a mixture of such complex
sequences
so moving on uh almost as surprising as
its arrival was the departure
uh by the end of april the frequency of
these oddball sequences started to go
away and by the beginning of may they
were gone i've sequenced the sewer shed
every week for since march
we have not seen a single lick of these
sequences again since
and i should mention there are they have
never been seen in a patient of the two
million sequences and just aid from
around the world none of them have
sequences that are even close to what we
were seeing from the sewer shed
so while we were finding these
oddball lineages in missouri and i was
really getting excited of what the heck
is going on i reached out to just about
everyone i could think of who was doing
wastewater surveillance across the
country to ask if they were seeing
similar things is this just very thing
and they all said the same thing which
is we don't know we're doing whole
genome sequencing we can't really tell
if there are new lineages but then i was
listening to my favorite podcast which
is called twiv and they had some guests
on from new york city who were actually
using the same approach that i was of
amplifying and sequencing the rbd
so i reached out to them and we had a
chat to see whether we were seeing
similar things and they basically said
we are seeing oddball polymorphisms but
we can't really tell if they go together
because they hadn't really worked out
the software yet and they also were
amplifying a much smaller piece of the
receptor binding domain so we decided to
collaborate and they sent me
almost the next day rna from all 14 of
the sewer sheds representing all the
boroughs of new york city and we
sequenced them all and it was it was
really cool it was like a who's who of
all the variants of concern
but there are also a handful of lineages
that did not match any of the known
lineages that you would find in the
database they were expressed in very low
amounts and they did not match the
sequences we were seeing in missouri but
they were very clearly unique
we went and did the same thing two weeks
later and we found exactly the same the
same exact things were still present it
wasn't some sequencing thing these were
um
present in this in particular sewer
sheds and they stayed geographically
constrained and interestingly they were
going up and frequency is seen
in retrospect we're pretty sure what's
happening is the amount of these oddball
sequences were remaining constant but
the amount of patient sequencing patient
rna at this point in time was going down
as there were fewer and fewer patients
but it didn't last as we all know
so this is a summary of
three of the sewer sheds and the wages
we saw from them
this is just the
showing the receptor binding domain one
of the things that really jumped out at
us is that all of the lineages from new
york which are they were very divergent
from one another but they all had a
mutation at position 498
and in particular a lot of them had the
mutation 498 y or
glutamine to tyrosine
now if you look on just aid there of the
two million sequences you this
particular change which actually takes
two nucleotide changes to make this one
amino acid change has never been seen in
a patient however it has been seen in an
adaptive model so a guy named ralph
barrica familiar was the first to make a
mouse adapted stars cov2 and one of the
mutations he made for making that was
q498y
so this is when at first the light came
on it's like oh maybe these are not
coming from humans these could be
affecting some other animal
i also want to point out this one from
wastewater treatment facility three
this was it's just crazy this receptor
binding domain has 16 amino acid changes
including a deletion of physician 484
which is a really key one for
evading class 2 neutralizing antibodies
and yet we recreated it and it was still
fully functional this is this is a real
sequence that's circulating somewhere
one thing we wanted to see is if it
actually has gained the ability to
infect other animals so again we
generated the sequences into our stars
co we do pseudo particles and we tested
different cell lines to express
different ace two
um so they could all infect cells that
have human ace too
but the red bar is the parent sequence
or the d614g as you can see
in the
cell lines that have mouse or rat ace2
you can see that the red bar is very low
because it cannot utilize those
receptors the blue bar is n501y a570d
that's the alpha variant which is known
to have gained the ability to infect
rodent cells and you can see they all
have enhanced infectivity in the mouse
and rat these two cell lines and all of
the mutations we looked all of the
variants we pulled out from new york
city stewardship had indeed gained the
ability to infect cells with mouse or
rat ace2
it doesn't mean that that's where they
came from but it at least is consistent
with the hypothesis that this might be
coming from
we also tested these guys against
centralizing antibodies and like in
missouri they all behaved exactly as
their genotype would predict
some of them were resistant to all three
classes
we also tested their neutralization with
serum from actual patients and in
general they were resistant
the patient's heroes always could still
neutralize but usually at a lower level
so we still don't know where these
sequences are coming from but the fact
that each sequence has remained
constrained to a particular sewer shed
for
about eight months now
really does not sound to me like it's
coming from humans we think it's coming
from some animal that is geographically
constrained so one of the things we've
done is we sequence the zomo rna from
our same sewer shed samples to see what
animals are contributing to the
wastewater and mostly what we found is
what you would expect which was we found
human ribosomal rna we find the thing
that's the humans eat because of course
these those are making the sword shed as
well so we saw a lot of cow pig sheep
goat chicken things we eat but the
things that
probably are uh could be something else
or the ones that are likely candidates
right now are cat dog and rat which were
all fairly frequently present in the
super shed
uh one of the other things we've been
doing is uh amplifying larger pieces and
uh sequencing it using a platform called
pac bio it's been a collaboration with
the university of wisconsin and the cdc
um it's pretty cool that uh you can see
this big piece like this this was one
sewer shed where there were only two
lineages uh the one the first one was
our oddball lineage and you can see it
the little blue this little square
around the rbd is the part we were
seeing before but when you see the whole
s1 region you can see there's lots of
big deletions and a bunch of other
changes
but the second one it lineage was very
clearly had all the polymorphisms
consistent with b.1.621 which i believe
is now called mu i think it's the latest
one that's been added to the grief
alphabet so this is another technology
that is is coming forward which could
really um shed light on variants within
the summer shed
so that's my last slide so
we submitted a manuscript with the new
york city work about three or four weeks
ago and about two weeks two days or two
or three days after we submitted the
manuscript the usda also submitted a
manuscript and in their case what they
were doing is surveillance of
white-tailed deer and lo and behold they
checked their serum and found that they
are very frequently have high levels of
antibodies against cervix kobe 2 which
almost certainly means they have been
infected so the finding that sars coe2
is in other animals is not particularly
surprising anymore
so let's remind you this was a
collaboration between university of
missouri department of health and
department of natural resources it was
actually the department of natural
resources that started this project
and
that i thank you for your time